baise moi 2 il est fort à une prime si
ça sort le 28 juin
vous avez lu les bouquins de bienvenue
dépend de vous j'ai lu j'ai lu les
jolies choses ça j'ai lu surtout
d'adaptations cinématographiques qui en
est faite
voilà maintenant je vous dis une
question quand on est libéral est ce qu
on est libéral haut niveau avec ceux ci
regarde pas avancer bien simplement où
il n'empêche pas d'avoir chacun une
petite boussole de valeur savoir comment
on se comporte pour cela se compte
estime bien ce qu'on estime mal mais
vous faites la vie vous voulez la double
peine et pour le numéro je devine que le
libre échange vous émoustille et pendant
ce temps là jean claude brialy ça vous
fait vos affaires touchant chez moi vous
assister en direct à un événement
extraordinaire ces gens qui utilisent
alors non je trouve que c'est magnifique
d'entendre des jeunes femmes qui ont une
main ferme t il
on sent aussi dans leur regard quelque
chose douloureux je trouve ces mots non
mais bon c'est le champagne n'a donné
qu'un jeu magnifique souvent les gens
viennent bande leurs affaires ouais et
tout est bien tout est bien et là on
sent qu une sincérité sur la secopex a
marqué la chose la plus belle qui soit
dans le dollar le dernière question
pardon patrick pépin dans la rue mais
ouais virginie vous en êtes où avec les
mecs là parce que quand on quand je vous
ai connus quand j
de paris dernière en 95 vous me disiez
ni garçon n'y fit je rentre chez moi
puisque je fais du sport je vais pas il
faut faire du sport pour courir pour
évacuer tout ça c'était un peu la
chasteté un peu triste ou y
non c'est un peu pareil merde boulot
mais vous avez un problème avec les mecs
parce que vous dites j'ai un problème
non pas avec les mecs j'ai un problème
avec tout ce qui est dominant bon et si
vous trouviez un mec qui soit pas
dominant mais c'est un emprunt avec les
mecs si tu as fait ça ça va avec ce qui
est dominant par contre ce n'est déjà
plus un problème
je préfère qu'on me foute la paix sur
tous ces services moi aussi à vous aussi
la bannière géante âgées sont appelés à
renouveler mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut pas
chiffrer à 900 cas vient de se tenir à
bakwa est ce que tu veux qu'on soit
soumis aux dominos ou est ce que tu veux
soumis sous mis d'accord je vais changer
un peu je serai ton chien
ok pas de problème bloqués parfois